it was all about
keeping their cool for many up and down
the land
that meant heading to the coast or
whatever water they could find
in western supermare the crowds enjoyed
some traditional seaside respite
it's the closest beach to birmingham but
at more than a hundred miles away
those who stuck with the city were
grateful for a patch of sand
at a fun fair it's really nice man
my parents have gone to wales so you
know i didn't really have any need going
with them because we got a beach right
here in birmingham you know
we're chilling i hate it i'm praying for
rain on
friday i think is can't wait like it boy
it's a bit
too hot bit worrying as well for the
child boy it is nice
i think enjoy it while it lasts because
you know what the british weather is
like they'll just uh you know
you gonna get like a week or two of it
and that's it it's all gone most of the
rides are high up
so if like when you're high up you get
lots of air because you get spinned
around and most of the high
rides for those who enjoy the heat
the weather is headed in the right
direction
it may be just a few minutes of air
conditioning but at four pounds ago it
feels
completely worth it today
it's hot and due to get even hotter
that's great news for the owners of this
fun fair which
due to covid was closed for nearly a
year
after the weather we've had recently i'm
hoping we have a very positive impact on
our business
last year or so has been terrible for us
really
so i is hoping now this is the the
beginning of the end of it
it could though already be the beginning
of the end of the heat wave too
it might only last a week with next
weekend
looking more unsettled lisa dowd sky
news